good morning believe nation today's
message is make it better over to you
Paul orful I lucky enough to be very
restless they some people call it a DD
and I was very good at leaving my
business I after the first three months
we hired a manager because I those
stores used to drive me nuts they were
very hectic and nerve-racking and my job
was really because of my restlessness
and I could be in the moment was going
store to store to store looking for what
people are doing right and exploiting it
could I make a lot more money
discovering some cool loot new idea than
hovering in that office of worrying
about stuff and I was working with very
capable people that knew how to run the
business very well I had good financial
controls but my job was always looking
for ideas to make it better and I always
had to find my job that everything went
beautifully without me but whatever I
did every day I made it better I think
isn't it extremely important message for
entrepreneurs I think that's what we do
as entrepreneurs is we just try to make
things better Paul's talk about making
his company better after he's already in
the management role and is trying to
build up and his biggest role as the
entrepreneurs the CEO of the owner is to
go and keep making every process better
I think it also applies them when you're
first starting up when you are first
creating a product or service you're
doing it because you want to make it
better than what is currently existing
the reason why i started the top 10
videos that's done so well on the
channel is because nobody else was doing
it i wish somebody else did it so I
didn't have to spend the insane amount
of time to create them and the higher
team to make these things because I just
wanted to be a consumer I started the
ends presso series because I wanted
something in the morning to kick start
my day to surround myself with great
ideas every single morning in a quick
hit to help me get going and nobody was
doing it so I wanted to do it I had to
do it and I think that's what we do is
entrepreneur
and and the biggest opportunity that you
will find is the one where you are
making something better you have the
restlessness you're upset you're
frustrated with the way some things are
done and the entrepreneurs are the
people who don't just complain about it
they aren't the ones to just say I wish
this thing happened they go out and they
make it happen they create that for
themselves and then they share it with
others because they're trying to make
the world better so the question that
they today is how are you trying to make
things better what's the frustration
you're feeling now and what is how did
your product or service solve it really
curious to find out leave in the
comments below I'll join the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day continue to believe and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events press